pumpkin spice lattes are overrated on so
many levels a they're played out at this
point first of all they're delicious as
I will probably order six in the
next nine weeks but they are credibly
incredibly overrated I'm tired of it
like can somebody please do something
like strawberry shortcake like if
Starbucks or the other is needed for the
fall can't you call it like changing
leaves latte like like give me some like
earthy tones like can you give me like
acorns latte can you give me like corn
corn maze latte I'm making a prediction
corn maze latte can take over
pumpkin spice latte we're only a decade
away from the 20 the 18 to 29 year olds
buying it as an ironic move like a
disposable camera